so you thought joe biden spent
several hundred years in the united
states senate trying to make it harder
for you to discharge credit card debt
being a shill for the credit card
companies and of course helping his
near-dwell relatives shake down foreign
governments or bribes but he did a lot
of other things
like at one point he was deep beneath
the earth
digging for coal to keep the lights on
here he is in 2008 remembering that
experience
hope you won't hold against me but i am
a hard
coal miner anthracite coal scranton
pennsylvania
okay that's where i was born and raised
and it's nice to be back in coal country
sorry correction it's anthracite cold so
it's for steel making it's hard coal
whoa takes a coal miner to know that
difference after he dug
coal then biden became a civil rights
leader obviously in a jailbreaker
and when he fixed our racial problems
here he went all the way to south africa
to free nelson mandela from robin island
watch
i had the great honor of being arrested
with our u.n ambassador
on the streets of soweto trying to get
to see him on robin's
ever knew island i got arrested trying
to see him when i went down to south
africa
nelson mandela i came back from south
africa trying to see nelson mandela and
getting arrested for
trying to see him on robin's island he
was in prison
yep he got arrested in south africa for
trying to do the right thing prison
changes a man you got to do the time to
count the time do you
but he didn't even phase joe biden he'd
grown up on the wrong side of the tracks
in wilmington
you remember the time he whipped corn
pop sorry ass with a chain
watch corn pop was a bad
dude and he ran a bunch of bad boys and
he cut off his six foot length of chain
he folded up he said you walk out
with that chain and you walk to the car
and say you may
cut me man but i'm going to wrap this
chain around your head
you thought he was useless that man has
skills
he's got skills he's done a lot of
interesting stuff he hasn't just stood
up and talked
gotten more hair plugs he's actually
done stuff and we learned about more of
that stuff today
during a visit to a mac truck facility
in pennsylvania
joe biden told us and this had not been
recorded by any of his many biographers
that he can in fact double clutch a quad
box
he used to drive an 18-wheeler
and if we don't drive an 18-wheeler man
oh yeah
i got to
has mark stein driven an atm we have no
idea can he double clutch a quad box
he's written a lot of great books best
sellers he joins us now to assess the
remarkable career
of the president united states mark
stein great to see you tonight can you
double clutch a quad box can you drive
an 18 wheeler
uh well i don't think none of us has the
skill set
that uh joe biden has and i utterly
deplore
your skepticism about this he in fact
when he went to
nelson when he went to rescue nelson
riddle spring him from prison
he was driving an 18-wheeler uh he
to rob an island he didn't realize you
couldn't go by road to robben island he
thought it was by
like rhode island where you can go by
road
so he was so he was uh driving an
18-wheel used to be a 23-wheeler but
corn pops stole
five of the wheels it's true
it's true that he wasn't a actually a
miner
but he has sniffed the hair of a miner i
mean we're getting a little
hung up on the details here when he said
he was a fighter pilot
he said he was a fighter pilot in the
spanish-american war
and you guys go bananas uh but in fact
he did once take a business class flight
to barcelona
in 1978. so we're getting a little
too uh we're getting i think a little
too hung up on
details here he has a rich life
you know so he's driven a 23-wheeler uh
if he's allowed to stay up late he likes
to watch wheeler fortune
that's a wheeler um he's not always
allowed to
sometimes he has to turn in after murder
she wrote sometimes he likes to watch
the wainscoting channel and count the
bead board from
left to right he has a very rich life
and nothing none of his fantasies
are as insane as the reality of putting
the defense secretary
in a plexiglas helmet as if you're going
to project him into space
so i think what you're saying if i could
just sort of boil down
your your analysis i think you're saying
that we need to appreciate what we're
calling now in 2021 joe biden's
lived experience well i'd actually
rather live
i mean joe biden is bored by policy he
can't finish
sentences even when he's got people in
his ear piece
uh telling him the words to say he tails
off in the sentences you know if he
starts uh talking about the economy
tells us but when you suddenly say to
him remember when you and corn pop
you're in that 18 wheeler and you had to
dynamite the mountain pass in
fulton county georgia uh because the
republicans were trying to get through
so they could audit the ballots there
and you were to dynamite the whole thing
with your 18-wheeler full of credit
cards
from the first national bank of wuhan
and suddenly
joe biden springs to life that's the
real joe biden
and this husk that they prop up in front
of the prompter
is the one we should get rid of
our cameraman is laughing by the way
which is the greatest of all compliments
mark stein
thank you as always for making sense of
a world gone mad appreciate it
thanks a lot tucker hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else